[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de atrás 24 y esta vez nos encontramos
en mont de marsan esta ciudad del
sudoeste francés acoge hace más de tres
décadas el más importante festival de
flamenco fuera de españa- recorrimos sus
calles conversamos con los artistas pero
también con los cientos de foráneos que
cada año llegan hasta aquí para aprender
un poco más sobre esta cultura avenida
de andalucía
[Música]
ah
no
una de las situaciones que explican la
permanencia de este festival es quizás
que las tradiciones del sur de francia
se parecen mucho a las de españa aquí
por ejemplo hay una plaza de toros sin
embargo en mont-de-marsan había también
una gran población gitana y una
emigración de españa' que sirvieron de
trampolín a el éxito de esta fiesta
flamenca
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a
y aunque por aquí hay un gusto por las
costas españolas en general y andaluzas
en particular vinculado a la fiesta que
tiene lugar aquí en julio cada año
alrededor de la plaza de toros también
está la historia de la ciudad con bares
donde hace mucho tiempo los gitanos pero
no sólo ellos tocaban flamenco pero
antón para visitar mi partido
efe
también hace 30 manuel y que era
presidente del consejo departamental y
su esposa antonia tuvieron la idea de
crear un evento alrededor de este arte
singular que es el flamenco que era
flamenco
festival me acaba evite el festival
nació en 1988 y tres años después
camarón estaba aquí en una suerte de
frenesí considerable fue un concierto
fundador de a fondo t
la público empezó a venir por curiosidad
por interés por el boca a boca y el
público se fue educando poco a poco de
hamilton
y hoy en día hay gente que viene por
curiosidad pero también por el interés
de descubrir algo que quizás no hubieran
conocido si no hubiera este festival
esto permite mezclar un público y toda
una creación contemporánea porque el
flamenco evoluciona mucho boku
es emblemático para artistas
emblemáticos como israel galván
comenzaron un público que en principio
no era un público flamenco flamenco o de
bajo y con ese lo cante jondo que no
conocía el cante jondo el baile o la
guitarra no era gente que iba a ver
danza en los grandes teatros parisinos
pero poco a poco lo que le interesa al
público llegó hasta aquí donde la
tradición se asoció a la creación a la
audacia el mañana con el ayer da sólo lo
lindo
a
[Música]
una de las particularidades de este
festival es que los artistas invitados
están obligados a dar una masterclass
donde marshall es una oportunidad única
entonces para tomar un curso con las
grandes figuras del flamenco
por eso los alumnos vienen de todas
partes del mundo
con clases de palmas así ha comenzado
cada día de la semana que han está esta
profesora de francés en polonia ha
pasado en el festival de mont marsan
hace 10 años que esta fiesta es una cita
obligada para la polaca que supo del
evento a través de su profesor en
varsovia
el long se ma pasión
las lenguas son mi pasión el francés es
mi favorita y luego la danza y el
flamenco este festival cae en una buena
fecha porque es la primera semana de
vacaciones e igual hace se exhibían a
casa y es bueno que ocurra en junio o
julio porque yo soy profesora y no puedo
durante el año y todos los festivales en
españa o andalucía se desarrollan en el
año al
año
en clases de palmas donde mejor se
aprende este género musical y tiene más
de 50 ritmos o palos que identificar y
contar para poder danzar y voluntarios
[Música]
la tarea no es fácil ni para los
expertos
es complicado
[Música]
ah
cuando sea si lo canta e interiormente
nos ayuda
y si hace falta constancia lo suyo es no
voluntad
pero estamos aprendiendo todos estamos
solo algunos minutos para cambiarse y
curso de danza para mí es acá con una de
las artistas de la nueva generación
lucía la piñón
vuelvo a marcar
y este
la clase cuenta con un cantaor lo que es
un privilegio y permite a los
estudiantes familiarizarse con esa
coordinación precisa que debe existir
contra el que baila y el que interpreta
[Aplausos]
y estoy muy contenta porque elegí muy
bien los niveles de mi curso de danza
aprendí mucho en el curso de palmas
porque el profesor nos dio muchos
detalles y luego pude aprovechar ese
conocimiento viendo los espectáculos
cuando le consejo
con qué hombro empieza
mira tu bloqueos está aquí cariño en una
sala contigua uno de los grandes nombres
del flamenco eva yerbabuena da una
masterclass
para ello el desafío es el mismo no
importa de donde vengan sus estudiantes
aquí no mete a la muñeca dentro cuando
empezaba yo siempre escuchaba a las
grandes figuras
tanto de la guitarra del baile del cante
es decir cuando les preguntaban qué es
el flamenco el flamenco es una forma de
vida el flamenco es un medio del
lenguaje el flamenco es un arte muy muy
visceral donde se comparten sentimientos
carencias sufrimiento entonces yo me
pregunto qué cultura en el mundo no ha
padecido todo esto o no comparte lo
mismo alegría que sufrimientos que
carencia que lo hacen a través de la
música a través del cante a través de la
danza
las alumnas pueden luego repasar en
escena cada uno de los aprendizajes que
les dejó la maestra
en el museo de la ciudad entre fotos y
esculturas que se hacen eco de los
movimientos del flamenco conversamos con
eduardo guerrero dueño de un flamenco
fusionado y contemporáneo y uno de los
bailarines más destacados de la nueva
generación
eduardo cómo comenzaste en el flamenco
pues en mi vida comienza en el flamenco
con seis años y va a la visita de casa
de la abuela y justo abajo estaba la
escuela de baile entonces que cada vez
que pasábamos por allí yo me asomaba a
esos barrotes y observaba lo que ocurría
dentro y una de las vías como un juego
de niño mamá yo quiero ir a bailar yo
quiero ir a bailar
en la siguiente visita que hacíamos a
casa de la abuela mi abuela me había
tenido un regalo y era una gotita de
baile con seis años en un pececito super
pequeño y me las coloque baje abajo al
estudio
y descubrir el maravilloso mundo del
arte eso quiere decir que no venía de un
círculo familiar flamenco nada mi
familia no se dedican ninguno al arte no
no tenemos ninguna artista en la casa
era una familia de futbolistas mi tío
era utillero del cádiz club de fútbol
mi hermano jugador profesional del cádiz
club de fútbol mi padre trabajaba en el
marcador del estadio y nosotros lo que
hacíamos era todos los domingos acudir
al estadio
y sí que es verdad que cuando empecé a
bailar justo en el intermedio que hay de
un tiempo del primer tiempo al segundo
tiempo le ponían música y ese era mi
momento de el domingo de la actuación yo
iba por la grada y por allí ponía la
música y yo aparecía por allí bailando
la gente aplaudiendo me daba es el hecho
quizás de no venir de una familia
flamenca o gitana lo que te ha permitido
un lugar como es crear algo nuevo en un
género en el que parece que a veces la
novedad no es bien recibida creo que
que eso también te da una libertad
puesto que al no reconocer tus padres
nada de lo que la intensidad de lo que
es lo más hondo dentro del flamenco
para mí era un descubrimiento todo lo
que me gustaba era bailar entonces
cualquier tipo de danza para mí era como
una esponja que llegaba a mí y se
quedaba dentro luego yo soy
una persona muy curiosa me encanta la
investigación me encanta lo nuevo me
gusta me llama la atención las cosas me
disfruta y
me llena de emoción cualquier
arte relacionado con la danza entonces
no le tengo ningún
ningún muro porque creo que también el
flamenco no hay que encasillar lo no no
hay que ponerle paredes puesto que es un
arte que está vivo y que está en
continuo crecimiento
creo que los muros no valen ni para el
flamenco ni para la vida en general que
representa justamente para ti mont de
marsan un festival que está fuera de
españa y que además lleno salas al
comienzo no por la danza sino que por el
cante flamenco conozco bien el festival
se la afición que existe aquí en francia
por el flamenco sobre todo en el
festival de mont de marsan
es un festival que acoge muy bien el
arte eso es maravilloso porque es un
público entendido es un público que
respeta las propuestas pero que sobre
todo viene a ver con carta blanca
cualquier espectáculo y eso es
maravilloso ya tengo como el flamenco es
tan amplio cada uno elige como lo quiere
presentar en este caso y yo ya llevo ya
muchos espectáculos atrás queriendo
contar cosas que ocurran de verdad y que
ocurran de verdad a la hora de
manifestarnos si realmente hay una
guerra y se tiene que hablar en el
espectáculo de guerra que se hable
porque somos los mayores exponentes
ahora mismo es una plataforma muy buena
para poder
manifestar lo que queremos lo que
queremos que se escuche de nosotros
entonces hacer un trabajo de lo que
actualmente ocurre del consumismo
de la violencia de género
de la sexualidad de las guerras de los
problemas políticos hay que hacerlo
gracias eduardo por esta entrevista con
france 24 nada gracias a vosotros por
haceros eco del arte que a mí me encanta
poder charlar con vosotros y nada
rodeado de arte nos despedimos un beso
para todos
y hasta aquí este capítulo de francia-
enfocó muchas gracias por su compañía y
hasta una próxima por las pantallas de
france 24 y / 234 puntocom